Статус кандидата на вступ до ЄС. Що це означає для України?
Які вимоги? І які наслідки за невиконання цих вимог?
Статус кандидата на членство в ЄС - не просто пафосний титул.
Він має цілком практичні переваги.
Зокрема, Україна зможе отримати конкретну фінансову допомогу, ставши повноправним членом програм та ініціатив Євросоюзу,
відкритих як для країн ЄС, так і країн зі статусом кандидата на членство.
Це особливо важливо на тлі війни Росії проти України.
Після перемоги Києва, коли б вона не сталася, це дозволить акумулювати кошти для відновлення країни.
Євросоюз ставитиметься до таких інвестицій не як до післявоєнної відбудови третьої країни,
а як до вкладання грошей у добробут потенційного нового члена ЄС.
Крім того, це сприятиме залученню й приватних інвестицій.
Буде більше довіри до України. Бізнес-клімат наближатиметься до умов, як у країнах Євросоюзу,
де інвестори діятимуть на ринку, який є передбачуваним, а бізнес - захищеним.
До того ж, статус кандидата на вступ до ЄС - це вже юридична категорія,
яка закріплює європейське майбутнє України і спонукатиме до проведення реформ та боротьби з корупцією.
Єврокомісія, рекомендуючи визнати Україну кандидатом на вступ до ЄС, назвала сім головних кроків.
Насправді ж це умови надання Україні статусу кандидата.
І що показово: виконати ці умови треба не до, а після отримання цього статусу.
Це реформа Конституційного суду, продовження судової та антикорупційної реформ, боротьба з відмиванням коштів,
втілення антиолігархічного закону, узгодження аудіовізуального законодавства з європейським та зміна законодавства про нацменшини.
Ідеться про Закон про освіту від 2017 року, який став причиною конфлікту між Будапештом і Києвом.
Прогрес у виконанні буде відстежувати Єврокомісія, і до кінця цього року вона ж має представити першу детальну оцінку того,
як Україна справляється зі своїми завданнями.
ЄС може переглянути рішення про кандидатство України, якщо умови надання статусу не виконуються.
Тобто теоретично Європейська Рада може забрати статус кандидата.
Щоправда, такого поки не траплялося в історії Євросоюзу.
Крім того, дедлайну виконання згаданих семи вимог теж немає. Та ще й в умовах воєнного стану.
Зрештою, рішення Єврокомісії щодо України та Молдови не має аналогів.
ЄС ще ніколи такого не робив і вигадав, по суті, гібрид.
Адже Брюссель, рекомендуючи надання статусу, водночас визнав, що Київ ще не готовий бути кандидатом в члени ЄС.
Статус кандидата на вступ до ЄС уже чимало років мають п'ять країн.
Найдовше - Туреччина. Її навіть називають "вічним" кандидатом.
Анкара отримала цей статус ще у 1999-му. Тобто 23 роки тому.
Перемовини щодо членства Туреччини в ЄС тривали з 2005 року,
але останні 5-7 років ці переговори фактично заморожені через, як вважають у Брюсселі,
порушення прав людини в країні.
Решта держав-кандидатів - балканські країни.
Північна Македонія має цей статус з 2005 року, Чорногорія - з 2010 року, Сербія - з 2012 року та Албанія з 2014 року.
На відміну від цих держав, в українському висновку Єврокомісії немає фрази
про запрошення України до переговорів навіть за виконання умов.
Це означає, що у майбутньому для цього Києву можуть висунути ще й додаткові умови.